e pronti prevista action ragazzette che
io non lo ero per niente quando
registrato episodio sappiatelo un attimo
ho pensato che avresti c'è tutto che non
saresti mai arrivato fin qui quindi ora
combattiamo i comincia un network che
pare la torre di pisa però va bene lo
stesso rubate resto deficiente è una
gara che per intero al peggio ma tu le
sai le trappole bastardo non vale non
vale ragazze se lui sa dove andare
stasera invece si passò soprattutto che
culo che culo questa cosa viene lo
sapevo lo sapevo hanno dunque ziati
svolazzo con la gonna non vorrei che ti
vedessero di sotto quindi è meglio stare
bassi non troppo bassi per non lo si può
fare garantivano come fare scusate ma io
torni indietro
cazzo che ci ho pensato st corna dai che
genialata o carica calmi calmi calmi
no eh vabbè ma se buttana cosa ha fatto
regala briga briga cosa sono cosa ma
cosa ma da dove arrivano si strada e
vuoi dirmi carte non ti hanno preso
hanno arato tutto quanto il campate non
tam preso fantastico calmo adesso vado
di so proprio che ci sono sì stronzi ok
se lo puoi buttare tutto dove devo
andare
2 vado lo so che vi sparano da tutti
morisse il fratello mica guardo se non
ottenevo fare sta parte veloce madonna
cosa ho fatto
c'è perciò ma perché non vado su perché
riesco a mantenere la calma forse ce la
faccio piano piano che adesso passare 18
perché sarebbe veloce una madre [ __ ]
non superato calcio forse lo ri figlio
pozzo rifinire ma quando anna che casino
è che cazzo si certo
dai roccia che caso no vabbè vabbè se
sempre per un c nel culo non è colpa mia
se va bene dove sono
sono ancora vivo giustamente come adesso
devo morire perché non mi ami ami ha
potuto letteralmente il traguardo so
stronzo che vi posso andare indietro
grazie dai cazzo che così non l'avevo
mai fatto
l'ansia merda dai dai dai sensi non è
così il castello credo sia alla fine ci
possa arrivare non è così impossibile
non è impossibile molto di più ciao bel
pupazzino è che cosa ci fai qui alla rai
addio un'esplosione di rosita immane non
l'ho capito fermi attimo che arriva
davanti
ok poi c'è la palla la devo saltare la
madonna e cioè una 2 a piano ragazze
piano piano una per una per volta ci
state tutte l'ho preso al volo ma riesce
a fare neanche un lancio come si deve
rendetevi conto io non anche ben capito
perché lo lanciate segalini fini magari
se riuscissi a
[Musica]
no non si può fare voi non l'ho capito
no no ma dovrò cazzo non è arrivare più
velocità
ce l'ho fatta non pensavo rossi non so
esattamente che cosa mi può servire per
hosting lui non mi piace infatti allora
cambiamo cina io non so che cosa ho
appena fatto ma sono sicuro che mi sono
salvato il culo ho capito già tutto devo
portare che cazzo è successo ci sono
allora presente devo fare così credono
no no no perfetto poi devo tornare
indietro non torna allora non ho capito
un cazzo edificio devi solo saltato e
così piano niente niente niente niente
niente
[Musica]
ok allora calmiamoci rossi tadini con me
perché mi servi io ti lancio l'aggiunta
di una gallina da ragazzina che posso
passare la puntata a farmi schiacciare
la palla di neve ma questo cos'è se non
ce l'ha no no no ho sbagliato mira ci
siamo adesso la prendo vado avanti o ma
perfetto
questo l'annuncio la cazzo ok no no l'ho
uccisa se ce la faccio sì sì già fatta
ok ho saltato un ostacolo per culo
non chiedetemi come la devo come come si
fa
devo passare di no caradonna e riesco a
saltare in qualche modo sta roba
sì che si riesca allora è facile cazzo
titolo prima vieni qui vi è no non
opportuno muori tu non muori muri dove
dico io forse un po più in là sarebbe
stato meglio ma va bene lo stesso
sì no no no no no no perché ho solo
detto no a tenervi rega perfetto ce la
posso fare non è posto di impossibile ok
ok ragazzi è veramente non so parole
adesso non mi dire che non ci arrivi
nome seriamente si accuserà non lo
pensavo funzionasse non mi stavo
veramente incazzato
meno male che ha funzionato cos'è sta
roba devo passare come faccio
[Musica]
che culo che tu lo calmi calmi danni ok
non faccio andare là e ma non ci riesce
a [ __ ] misa di notte sì magari magari
qualche elicottero che cade già che ci
siamo in clima se ce l'ho fatta
briga caminati degli ultimi maggio 2010
lista che ti del infilo super il
deretano forma non so neanche che cosa
cazzo ho fatto per riuscirci tutta la
pazienza del mondo ragazzi con tutta la
pazienza del mondo è impossibile ok ok
si no no mica ci stavo andando di nuovo
meno male adesso lo lanciò bene adesso
ci arrivo ci arrivo bravo sia
ringraziato ed io chi è quel ragazzo
chiesto tizio è così che io stringo
amicizia ragazzi salto sull'ex la testa
delle persone poi loro diventano mie
amiche scommetto che si scappa lo sapevo
che saltava sulla sua testa vuol dire
che c'era un motivo quindi devo fare
fare schifo devo fare schifo che mira di
merda ciò ma neanche rea che prendere le
cose ferme cioè che fermi
ok ok ok mezz'ora per fare sta merda
mezz'ora c'è una cosa urna non so se
dici di come un porting rocket che
scompare la velocità della luce
se devo essere sincero davanti o che chi
cazzo sei tu fai le presentazioni non ho
idea di chi tu sia ma ti lancio una
gallina un mio omaggio va bene o maggio
sto gran cazzo sirti saltò addosso mi
prendi in braccio si 6 [ __ ] ragazzi mi
spiegate per favore che cosa dovrei fare
mezza e mezz'ora che sono tutti calmi
[Musica]
mi piace non c'è verso che poi non è
tanto difficile ok non è tanto difficile
mi porto la gallina no non è che la
lancia la sua pratica tradizionale caffè
mi è uscita salve sale senta lea ecco
perché grazie
cosa fa o capi lancia mi si no
sono anch'io deficiente quanto basta
complimenti ragazzi devo farmi lanciare
no ecco perfetto nord non non giu
possibilmente una minaccia in testa vai
vai bene vai
sì sì ho fatto mia lista ragazzi datemi
un datemi un ascia un qualcosa ti
ammazzo regalo io mi butto sulla sulla
bandiera provo un attimo come lei non si
è fatta niente quindi non mi faccio
nulla neanch'io
adesso io devo sono fermi la frutta no
no no sì sì sì ok ok non so perché prima
son caduto forse perché eravamo in due
il peso non ha retto forse non lo si
conduce andrea calmarmi le capre che
stava morendo giura una cosa assurda è
niente reca comunque se il video è
piaciuto lo stesso documento mi piace
anche a pagliari facebook e con i video
trovate nella descrizione senese
dovresti discatori ci mettiamo un
prossimo video per ragazzi